if you're really into the hit Netflix
series dark we're here to brighten your
day with five other titles that are
totally worth checking out on this
week's binge guide the first ever German
series produced by Netflix just released
its third and final season but more
importantly recently one our bracket
style competition on what the best
Netflix original series is so if you're
a fan of dark and Netflix is other Syfy
hit stranger things and maybe you should
check out these five shows next starting
with our certified fresh pick a
counterpart this star show has to 100%
certified fresh seasons and features a
dual performance from Oscar winner JK
Simmons playing characters from parallel
dimensions in cold war-era Berlin along
with heaping praise on the fantastic
work from Simmons critics call this show
an absorbing throw fest which finds time
to deliver relevant societal critiques
taking the 20 hours to binge this one
should also be enough time to figure out
if you want to meet your counterpart
from another dimension and I am so down
next is the heart audience Pig and it's
going to the NBC show timeless the
passionate fan base help push this one
through multiple cancellations and ended
up getting two seasons and ultimately a
two-part Christmas special slash series
finale following a trio who travelled
through time to battle a master criminal
out to alter history critics called
timeless a fun throwback action series
that will leave viewers giddy with
adventure with a pinch time of about 23
hours this show will give you all the
joys of time travel without all the cost
and moving on to our under-the-radar pic
it's going to twelve-month ease this
series had four fresh seasons on Sci Fi
and is a loose adaptation of the 1995
first Willis movie of the same name it
follows the time traveler from the
post-apocalyptic future comes back to
2015 on a mission to save mankind from a
deadly plague and now I'm totally
freaked out the critics say this show is
full of addictive twists high-quality
execution and cool characters which help
it overcome some time-traveling logic
issues after getting through all four
seasons in just under 33 hours you might
as well go back and watch the movie too
because you know Bruce Willis and for
our throwback pic this week we're
heading all the way back to 2008 for
show fringe with five straight fresh
seasons this sci-fi thriller that was
co-created by JJ Abrams is about an FBI
agent that explores unexplained
phenomena with the help of an
institutionalized scientist and his son
with familiar faces like Joshua Jackson
and Anna Torv leading the way critics
considered fringe one of the best
science fiction shows on TV a decade ago
calling it action-packed suspenseful and
filled with intriguing twists after you
get through all 100 episodes and around
76 hours you can go check out a Natur of
a mine hunter and Joshua Jackson in the
affair oh and of course Dawson's Creek
and finally our editor's pick this week
is going to Hulu's Castle Rock this
psychological horror series with two
certified fresh' seasons is set in the
Stephen King multiverse intertwining
characters and themes from the fictional
town of Castle Rock led by an impressive
cast it includes big names like Lizzy
Caplan
Jane levy Tim Robbins and Bill skarsgård
critics call this show a meticulously
crafted mystery brimming with illusions
you can binge it in 20 hours and then
spend the rest of your life reading
every Stephen King book that takes place
in Castle Rock good luck all right
friends hopefully this will help
brighten or darken your next you binge
session be sure to let us know what you
are currently streaming in the comments
and if you don't want to miss out on any
future recommendations based on the
movies and shows that you love be sure
to check back here and hit that
subscribe button and notification bell
so you don't miss out on any future
episodes of the rotten tomatoes [ __ ]
guy fight